duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh impeachment time
that's right i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show they may get the sense
that I'm not taking this super seriously
that's because I'm kind of not this show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn stop putting your online data
at risk get protected at expressvpn comm
slash Ben ok so the reason I'm not
taking this supremely seriously is
because everybody knows where this is
going
the Democrats are gonna vote to impeach
President Trump in the house and then
the Republicans are gonna vote to acquit
in the Senate it's that simple that's
where this is going the only question is
whether there is some sort of new
bombshell that has dropped and given the
witness testimony that we expect the
answer is probably not the answer is
probably not
the only other question here is whether
Democrats are going to be capable of
sinking president from sort of public
relations stance are you gonna see the
support for impeachment rise just
because there's so much bad press
surrounding impeachment and because
President Trump continues to insist
against pretty much all the evidence
that the phone call with Ukraine was
absolutely perfect nothing wrong with it
absolutely 100% what Abraham Lincoln
would have done right that is not the
reason that's not a smart strategy
honestly in terms of public relations in
terms of impeachment that really matter
what a strategy is what's gonna be is
what's gonna be but in terms of public
relations the reason that's not a smart
strategy is the same reason it is not a
brilliant idea to go out at the
beginning of your presidency and say we
are going to have 5% growth every year
for the rest of my tenure the reason
it's not smart to say that is because if
you come in at 4% which is great then
everybody goes oh well you said five and
you completely missed the boat well if
you say that everything with Ukraine was
absolutely 100 percent perfect
unbelievable and then people like well
then look that perfect to me it makes
them more suspicious of your entire
claim that's why it is a bad public
relations strategy as I've been saying
from the beginning the president is not
his own best lawyer but of course today
is when the public impeachment hearings
begin ooh
public impeachment Herrington all of
these hearings are basically going to
repeat the testimony that we saw behind
closed doors there are no real surprise
witnesses here Democrats have not
approved many of the witnesses the
Republicans want yesterday I talked a
little bit about the witnesses that
Republicans wanted president Trump had
put out a list compiled by
representative Jim Jordan of Ohio who is
currently sitting with the House
Intelligence Committee he sort of been
swapped in any sort of a wringer
brought in to do some of the questioning
because he's good at this sort of thing
and Jordan had released a list of the
witnesses that Republicans would like to
see on that list were people like hunter
Biden and Joe Biden right because Jordan
wanted to ask okay well was there
something nefarious going on in Ukraine
and if there was something nefarious
going on in Ukraine or suspicious with
hunter Biden why is it illegitimate of
Trump to ask the Ukrainian government to
investigate all that apparently they
also wanted to bring in the
whistleblower Democrats have been quite
reticent to bring forward the
whistleblower why well because they
understand that there is pretty good
information that the whistleblower is a
Democratic operative that the
whistleblower is somebody who's a
lifelong Democrat who works from the
Obama administration who is good or at
least close relatively speaking with
Vice President Joe Biden who was close
with James clapper the Director of
National Intelligence and because of
that the Democrats are concerned that if
this person is brought forward in
question it's going to turn out this
person was coordinating with the head of
the chair of the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff and that this
whole thing was put together behind
closed doors now that would not in and
of itself to bunk the claims made about
Trump and Ukraine but it would go to
motive and Democrats understand that
would be a bad public relations move for
them to allow that testimony because the
first thing that would happen is that
Trump would say witch-hunt and most
Americans would say 'ya kind of because
unless the crime is serious enough that
we actually believe it overcomes it that
it was it was not a partisan thing it
was actually just a this is a danger to
the country thing that's gonna be the
Republican plays so it's kind of weird
it's sort of parallel on the one side
the Republicans aren't going to claim
and this is really what it's going to
come down to Senator John Kennedy
finally coming around to adopting the
only real defense to Trump's activity
which is that it comes down to intent
and on the Democratic side the American
people are gonna have to decide
Democrats intent here's what I mean by
this so John Kennedy made clear that
when the question is what was Trump
intending to do in Ukraine was he
attempting to quote-unquote
get Joe Biden was the goal here to get
Joe Biden in advance for the 2020
election in order to sink his perceived
strongest opponents in the Democratic
primaries or to or to knock him out in a
general election or was this more what I
have suggested which is Donald Trump has
a bunch of weird ideas floating around
in his head about Ukraine he knows that
there was something going on in Ukraine
with regard to the 2016 election he
realizes that the Ukrainian
Embassy was coordinating with Alexandra
chalupa who was an operative for the DNC
and they were coordinating with the
Hillary Clinton campaign to dig up dirt
about Paul Manafort and presumably about
President Trump he recognizes all that
he also recognizes Ukraine has a long
history of corruption and he's
suspicious that some conspiracy theories
are true that Hillary Clinton's server
is somewhere in Ukraine buried in a
forest or something and that he is
suspicious that Joe and hunter Biden
were coordinating in order to get hunter
Biden a nice salary from a very corrupt
company allegedly called Purisima and
and that all of this was wrapped up in
his head and so when people said to him
do you want to give the 80 Ukrainian
said no I want all those things
investigated all of them and and so it
really wasn't about 2020 or getting Joe
Biden specifically it was about he had a
bunch of weird ideas floating around in
his head so it's not a good thing that
he mentioned Joe Biden in this context
it leads people to believe that he is
that he's manipulating the international
system and American taxpayer dollars for
personal political gain but that's not
actually what's going on right so that's
a question of intent
Senator John Kennedy explained this just
the other day he said yeah I mean well
in the end this is going to come down to
a question of intense and a question of
motive to possible scenarios number one
the president asked for an investigation
of a political rival number two the
president asked for an investigation of
possible corruption by someone who
happens to be a political rival the
latter would be in the national interest
the former would be in the president's
parochial interest and would be over the
line I think this case is gonna come
down to the president's intent his
motive did he have a culpable state of
mind okay I'm glad to hear that John
Kennedy the senator from from Louisiana
is finally coming around to the case
have been making with regard to this
thing for literally months at this point
and I think this is the case that
Republicans are going to end up coming
around to now there's a question of
intent on the right side of the aisle
didn't get to the question of intent on
the left side of the aisle in just one
second first let's talk about how you
make your company better so let's say
that there were somebody in your sound
Department somebody who are fresh on
some of the tibetan shapiro show let's
call them Robin and let's say that it
was like Robins first day and Robin just
to get there late and you're like you
know what Robin nice person but I'm
sorry we need to replace you with
somebody where would you look the place
you'd look is zip recruiter calm of
course zip recruit is where you go to
enhance all of your employment also you
don't have to fire Robin in order to
enhance your employment can bring in new
employees who are fantastic because zip
recruiter helps you file through the
best employees and find the best
employees with results like these it's
no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiting at
a quality candidate within the very
first day zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our web address
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire that
zip recruits calm slash Dai ly WI re its
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast zip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them for you instead and then
helps you filter all of those candidates
go check out zip recruiter right now for
free and our web address zip recruit
comm slash daily wire at zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire ok so as
I say there's a question of intent on
the Trump side of the aisle and then
there is in terms of public relations
the question of intent on the Democratic
side of the aisle and this is the case
that Trump is gonna make do you really
believe that Democrats are all fired up
set about Ukraine or is this just part
of a long campaign of Democrats wanting
to get rid of Trump is this really about
a sincere effort to protect the
presidency in the Constitution or is
this they hate me they've wanted me out
since literally the day I was elected
and before that they wanted insurance
policies against me according to text
from Lisa page and and and and Peter
struck right and that's exactly why the
Democrats are hiding this whistleblower
because I think that the whistleblower
is probably going to make it pretty
apparent that Democrats were in fact
motivated by partisan animus they were
not motivated by some desire to protect
the country so that is how these
impeachment hearings open according to
the Associated Press the closed doors of
the Trump impeachment period Trump
impeachment investigation are swinging
wide open the hearings are already
underway when the gavel strikes at the
start of the House hearing Wednesday
morning America and the rest of the
world will have a chance to see and hear
for themselves for the first time about
president Donald Trump's actions toward
Ukraine and consider whether they are in
fact impeachable offenses it's a
remarkable moment even for a white house
full of them says the AP all on TV
committee leaders will
the stage then comes the main feature
two seasoned diplomats William Taylor
the graying former inferred infantry
officer now charged a fair in Ukraine
and George Kent's the deputy assistant
secretary in Washington telling the
striking if sometimes complicated story
of a president using allegedly foreign
policy for personal and political gain
ahead of the 2020 election now we have
to examine exactly what these people are
going to be testifying to the Democrats
are laying out their bar okay and their
bar is no longer that Trump was simply
trying to influence American elections
that this was over at bribery the
president Trump was trying to bribe the
Ukrainians with American military aid in
order to foster his 2020 ambitions now
they can't name the statute the Trump
has violated here because he hasn't
violated any statute is the dirty little
secret of all of this and Democrats
basically acknowledged this but at least
colloquially they are now accusing Trump
of bribery so Adam Schiff tea house and
tell Jared who spent the last several
years pitching a pup tent outside of the
CN n greenroom in order that he could be
there at the drop of a hat Adam Schiff
says the impeachable offenses will
include bribery this will be the central
obviously claim of the Democrats is that
Trump was attempting to bribe the
Ukrainians and in return the Ukrainians
were attempting to bribe from here a
chef I don't think any decision has been
made on the ultimate question about
whether articles impeachment should be
brought but on the basis of what the
witnesses have had to say so far there
are any number of potentially
impeachable offenses including bribery
including high crimes and misdemeanors
the basic allegations against the
president or that he sought foreign
interference in a US election that he
conditioned official acts on the
performance of these political favors
okay so ship is going to be pushing
bribery Jackie Speier another one of
these Democrats by the way the best part
of that clip is shift saying that he
doesn't know whether impeachment charges
are going to be brought yeah sure okay
Jackie Speier is saying the same thing
so this is becoming a Democrat talking
point so if the Republican talking point
is going to be motive the Democratic
talking point is gonna be bribery and
the media are dutifully repeating this
right they've decided they are no longer
going to use the language quid pro quo
which is more accurate right because the
question is not whether a quid pro quo
happened right that part is factually
established that there was
some sort of quid pro quo that was
attempted a Trump was exchanging
military aid for something right he was
he was holding back military aid in
exchange for something now the the White
House is claiming no in reality he
wasn't really because they ended up
releasing the aid without getting the
something
yeah that's backfilling the story the
question is why the aid was delayed in
the first place okay what has been
pretty well established is that Trump
was holding back the aid for a reason
that is a quid pro quo the question is
whether it's a decent quid pro quo or an
illegal quid pro quo so Democrats are
saying bribery and the media are
dutifully repeating the idea that
bribery has been established when in
fact that is in fact the entire question
here's Jackie Speier again repeating the
word bribery are getting here bribery a
lot you're gonna hear extortion a lot
these are the two terms the Democrats
have decided on also because it sounds a
lot more serious than quid pro quo
because many Americans don't understand
what quid pro quo means being bribery
for some time the elements of bribery
are there you have a president using his
official office using taxpayer money to
demand from a foreign government that
they are bribed to do an investigation
to dig up dirt on the president's
opponent in the upcoming election the
corrupt intent is there as well in many
ways probably the most obvious is that
they put the transcript or the summary
of that phone call on July 25th into a
special server okay there are there are
a few holes in what she is saying here
hole number one is that Giuliani was
already in Ukraine attempting to dig up
dirt presumably on the Biden's number
two when she says that the the evidence
of guilt is that they hid the transcript
on the private server or on the unnies
and they sort of protected electronic
server yeah except that the New York
Times has reported that Trump has been
doing that document since basically the
beginning since everybody in his
administration works for Obama and then
wanted to leak all that information so
that is actually not dispositive okay so
in a second we're going to discuss who
exactly are the witnesses for today
because there are eight witnesses who
are expected to testify within the next
week in the house impeachment inquiry
will tell you who those are and what are
the people you're gonna hear from today
who are you excited are you excited
I'm not we'll get to all of that in just
one second first I know you do know how
to online shopping these days because
you got Thanksgiving coming up and then
got Christmas and Hanukkah coming up
depending on which religion you are all
sorts of gift-giving holidays
for people in a wide variety of cultures
and that is why you're doing a lot of
online shopping well when you're online
shopping how would you like to just save
money I don't really have to do anything
to save the money I mean like you will
just save the money by virtue of being
online how can you do this well instead
of searching for all of these discount
coupon codes and all this why don't you
just get honey okay honey is great it's
a free browser extension that
automatically finds the best promo codes
whenever you shop online
honey is found it's over 10 million
members over a billion dollars in
savings I've saved probably thousands of
dollars via honey at this point it works
on all the shopping sites including
amazon.com honey supports over 20,000
stores online and they have over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
the google chrome store if you're buying
gifts this holiday season then you do
need honey if you're not you probably
know somebody who does
who is so do them a salad and tell them
about honey again there's no reason not
to save money I just you literally put
it on your computer it just runs in the
background to your computer and then
every time you check out then it scans
the internet for the coupon codes and
help save you money it's free I mean
what like it's free money for you get
honey for free join the honey calm slash
pen again that's join honey calm slash
Ben join honey calm slash Ben go check
them out right now okay so the witnesses
who are expected to be called over the
course of the next week include
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander of Inman
who was a member of the National
Security Council he is an advisor to the
National Security Council and he was on
the Ukraine call so he can testify as to
what he heard Gordon sunland who is the
US ambassador to the EU whose national
important witness because Gordon sunland
is the only person of whom I'm aware in
this entire shebang except for Rudy
Giuliani who is coordinating directly
with President Trump so he may have more
of a window into what Trump was thinking
than anybody else who's been involved in
these conversations basically Sunland
was talking to Trump but Bill Taylor
wasn't talking to Trump Kurt Volker
wasn't talking to Trump Murray Ivanovic
wasn't talking to Trump so if you are
trying to pin intent on Trump you have
to talk to somebody who talked to Trump
right you can't to talk to you can't
talk to somebody who talked to somebody
who talked to somebody who talked to
somebody who talked to Trump right
that's not going to establish motive
there's no real way to do that so
Sunland will be a key witness Kurt
Volker the former special envoy to
Ukraine who was involved in a lot of
these negotiations but again was not
having direct negotiations with Trump
himself it was all filed through Mick
Mulvaney or through Gordon Sunland there
will be two State Department officials
who are the first witnesses to testify
publicly these are the guys who are
testifying today Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State George Kent
and acting ambassador to Ukraine William
Taylor and each one of them there they
have an account to tell but their
account is in fact somewhat secondhand
so begin with George Kent
so the Washington Post has a pretty good
rundown on this they say he's a deputy
assistant secretary at the State
Department overseeing European and
Eurasian affairs like Bill Taylor the
Acting US ambassador in Ukraine
Kent appears to have been privy to how
Trump's point people were trying to get
Ukraine to do his bidding and how those
efforts were viewed by other
administration officials he was
regularly talking to Taylor and he heard
about Trump's phone call with Ukraine's
president from the person who set it up
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander bin Minh so
here's the problem
George Kent has never talked to Trump he
was not on the original phone call the
only thing that George Kent really has
to say is how people outside of Trump's
very very core inner circle perceived
Trump's actions but as I've said before
that doesn't establish motive
that's like we're trying to establish
motive and a murder right and I watch it
on the news I see that there's there's
news about the murder on the news I have
an opinion about the motive of the
person who committed the murder or
committed the the homicide was it
self-defense or was an actual murder we
don't know
okay well the only way you're gonna know
that is by talking to the person who
actually committed the crime
you can't talk to somebody who talked to
somebody who talked to somebody who
talked to somebody who may have talked
to the person who committed the alleged
crime and so when you talk about George
Kent here's what he's testified so far
because all these people remember have
already testified behind closed doors he
testified according to the Washington
Post that Trump wanted Ukraine's newly
elected President Vladimir zalenski to
publicly and explicitly announced he'd
be investigating matters involving
Democrats and wanted him to used words
Biden and Clinton but here's the problem
Kent did not hear this directly from
Trump but rather from other officials
who talked to people who talked to Trump
and not even other officials we talked
to Trump other officials who talked to
people who talked to Trump so we are now
hearing this fourth and fourth hand from
George Kent I love the watch how the
Washington Post couches this in the
absence of people who talked directly to
Trump testifying reliably Kent made the
starkest claim yet that the White
House's effort to get Ukraine to root
out corruption was actually an attempt
to make them dig up dirt on Trump's 2016
opponent Hillary Clinton and a potential
2020 opponent former VP Joe Biden but
the key part of that sentence is in the
absence of people who talked directly to
Trump so what exactly
is George Kent going to say that you and
I don't already know Kent testified
about how corrupt Ukrainians recruited
Trump's personal lawyer to attack US
officials with a campaign of lies about
then ambassador Murray Ivanovich which
eventually made its way to the president
and I guess that that lends some color
to the idea that Rudy Giuliani was
feeding bad information to the President
of the United States via some of his
Ukrainian colleagues but again there's
nothing illegal about Rudy Giuliani
feeding bad information to the President
of the United States unless he was
acting as an actual forum lobbyist in
which case that's a that's a kernel
problem for Giuliani
but being fed bad information and acting
on that bad information by President
Trump is not illegal or impeachable it's
bad judgment it's not illegal or
impeachable from Ken's private testimony
kent said POTUS wanted nothing less than
president Solinsky to go to the
microphone and say investigation Biden
and Clinton
that's what Ken said he heard in a text
from Taylor okay but again Taylor was
not talking to Trump nor was he privy to
the conversations between Trump and
zalenski so what exactly does Kent have
to do with anything basically they're
now bringing in MSNBC commentators and
it could be 5-minute able moves
commentators to talk about what they
think of Trump's actions that is not
impeachable stuff it's not impeachable
stuff now the truth is that George
Kent's has said a couple of things that
are actually kind of helpful to
Republicans he testified in his close
testimony that if hunter Biden was on
the board of the Ukrainian national
natural gas company Purisima well Joe
Biden was VP that that was a conflict of
interest he also testified that he
raised those concerns with the Obama
White House and was rebuffed and told
quote there was no further bandwidth to
deal with Hunter and so that's testimony
from George Kent that could in fact
actually be damaging to the Democratic
to the Democratic Bush okay so that is
witness number one who's being brought
forth today then there's witness number
two is being brought forth today and
that is Bill Taylor Bill Taylor is the
guy whose test who was texting with
Gordon son Lindy EU ambassador as well
as kurt volker the special envoy it's
Ukraine when the three of them appeared
to be sort of trying to navigate the
thickets of Trump's thoughts trying to
navigate the thickets of what exactly
does Trump want in order to restore this
aid now again the problem with the
charge d'affaires bill Taylor is that
he's not the one who was actually
talking to Trump and the reality is
there's only one chain of command that
Matt
in this whole story and that chain of
command is Trump's real inner circle the
people who actually were talking with
Trump about this thing like when you're
try see I've been saying this about
impeachable offenses for a while and
criminal and in criminal conduct or or
political scandals for a while the only
political scandals that in the end tend
to stick to politicians are the ones
that are inherently personal which is
why sex scandals tend to be very sticky
no pun intended for politicians the fact
is that a lot of politicians right if
you have a financial scandal you can
always blame it on somebody else if
you're Barack Obama and your IRS starts
targeting conservatives randomly then
you can always say well listen I didn't
tell anybody to do that they just kind
of went and did that without my
permission and then we policed it it's
very difficult to pin down a scandal on
a politician that is not directly
connected to the politician sex always
is directly connected to the politician
literally physically so it's very easy
to get a politician caught in a sex
scandal because we're gonna blame it on
their aide right there's no way to blame
it on a chief of staff or something but
when it comes to a crime an alleged
crime like this you need to establish as
John Kennedy said the requisite intent
right you have to establish motive on
the part of the President of the United
States the only people who can do that
are the people talking directly to the
president so all of this testimony from
people who apparently have never talked
to President Trump like Bill Taylor has
never had a conversation with President
Trump so far as I'm aware that doesn't
make a difference right his his
reasoning is perfectly plausible I'm not
saying that the bill Taylor's testimony
isn't the applause will take on events
I'm just saying it is not a dispositive
take on events it is not evidence right
it is his perception of the situation it
is not evidence that what he believes
happened actually happened so the
Washington Post also sums up who Bill
Taylor is he's the acting US ambassador
to Ukraine also known as the charged
affair Taylor is also a career diplomat
and military veteran who has served in
Republican and Democratic
administrations including US ambassador
to Ukraine from 2006 to 2009 he was
asked by Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
to take over after Trump had Murray
Ivanovitch removed from the
ambassadorship he said it was a tough
decision to return to Kiev but
ultimately he accepted Pompeyo request
he was not in the room as the Washington
Post acknowledges where the alleged quid
pro quo orders were issued but he was
talking to many people who were in the
key rooms both in Washington and in Kiev
so again we have second hand or third
hand testimony in his closed
testimony he was asked specifically if
he'd ever spoken to President Trump he
said I have not he was not present on
the July 25th phone call with Ukraine he
said I received no readout of the call
from the White House and his allegations
what were they based off of right here's
the question answer with with Taylor
from his clothes testimony question it's
your inference that mr. Giuliani's goal
would be the president's goal Taylor yes
and your sources the New York Times
Taylor yes so you do not have any so do
you have any other source that the
president's goal in making this request
was anything other than the New York
Times Taylor I have not talked to the
president I have no information from
what the president was thinking so again
this is Democrats trotting out people
who have perceptions and their
perceptions are as valid as your
perceptions may be slightly more valid
in the sense that they actually know
about Ukraine know about Ukrainian
politics know some of the players but if
the idea here is that they can offer the
damning testimony that gets Trump nope
nope the Washington Post that was
talking him up
they say he testified that he learned
via conversations with White House aides
and national security officials and
Trump's point people in Ukraine there
was a concerted effort to force Ukraine
into a quid pro quo if it won in
military aid and an oval office meeting
Ukraine's President needed to publicly
agreed to investigate Democrats what's
critical about Taylor's testimony is
that he didn't attribute this to one
conversation with one person he talked
to high-level officials at the National
Security Council officials in Ukraine's
presidential office and two of the three
amigos designated by Trump to handle
Ukraine policy outside the normal
diplomatic channels Taylor said he was
in the regular Channel he said he was
also in the irregular Channel now
they're a bunch of people who have
similar perceptions of all of this
Taylor's testimony was corroborated by a
bunch of other people including National
Security Council official Tim Morrison
Gordon sunland originally testified he
didn't remember offering Ukraine a quid
pro quo to unfreeze its military aid but
then sunland went back and revised all
of that this is why the testimony that's
really going to matter here his
sunland's testimony even in his own in
his own testimony by the way Taylor
explicitly said that Trump could didn't
direct all of this and he didn't know
from directed all of this so Lee Zeldin
asked him where was this condition
coming from if you're not sure if it was
coming from the president and Taylor
said I think it was coming from mr.
Giuliani and Zeldin said but not from
the president now said I don't know
again this is gonna come down to do they
subpoena Giuliani does Giuliani have to
testify and what exactly does Giuliani
have to say okay in just one second
we're gonna get to the outstanding
questions here also we're gonna
introduce you to some of the players so
you're gonna be hearing about in the
very near future because they are not
actual members of Congress they're just
advising the Democrats and advising the
Republicans we'll give you their
background and it gives you a window
into the strategy being pursued by both
Democrats and Republicans we'll get to
all of that in just one second first
it's like it is imperative to own home
insurance in fact in many states you
actually have to by law
own a home insurance the insurance
experts of policy genius don't actually
think that getting the best home
insurance should be complicated and
that's why they've reimagined the entire
process start by answering a few quick
questions so the team can get to know
you and your property then policy genius
will help you to compare your policy
against more than ten other insurance
companies to make sure that you're
actually getting the best home insurance
coverage at the best possible price if
there is a better rate out their policy
genius will do all the heavy lifting and
get you switched over and by the way if
you're already getting paid again if
you're already paying your best rate the
policy genius will team will reshape
your policy for you every single year to
make sure that you actually are
continuing to get the best updated rate
you can bundle your home and auto
insurance as well policy genius has
saved their customers an average of 690
bucks per year on home and auto
insurance oh and they are offering sweet
deals competition makes the world a
better place
whether you need home insurance for a
new place or you just want to reshape
your current policy head on over to
policy genius calm tonight you can get
started on your smartphone right now
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy home insurance again that's
and buy home insurance go check them out
right now okay so they're a bunch of
outstanding questions that we still need
answered in this impeachment inquiry
amber Phillips over at the Washington
Post actually has a fairly good roundup
of the questions that still need
answering and the fact is Democrats are
not gonna get the answers from the
witnesses that they are proposing to
interview right now question number one
who is directing all of this did Trump
himself order aid withheld to pressure
Ukraine to investigate his political
opponents or were some people in his
administration acting of their own
volition or their interpretation of what
he wanted and by the way that last
phrase is the key their interpretation
of what he wanted what we have seen with
President Trump over and over and over
again is that people who work for him
are constantly trying to forecast what
he wants the most obvious example as
there is talk back when Trump was
visiting
South Korea that people had ordered the
cover-up of the USS John McCain like the
logo of the USS John McCain and then it
turned out Trump hadn't ordered any of
that it was just some intrepid
forward-thinking member of his
administration trying to please him
preemptively this is it possible that
people around him were saying things
like yeah you know I can see the Trump
is really bothered by all of this but
the thing he's really bothered by is Joe
Biden and so we really need the Joe
Biden's statement the statement will
probably pleased Trump like treated
Trump to man the statement or was that
something concocted by other members of
his team in order to sort of pleased
Trump and that makes a difference
because again to go back to the Obama
IRS example let's say you wanted to
impeach Barack Obama back in 2015 over
the over the Lois Lerner IRS scandal
they were targeting conservative 501 C
3s and preventing them from receiving
their 501 C 3 status on the basis of
ideology of a violation of IRS
regulation and the First Amendment and
he said okay well Obama clearly wanted
that to happen who's going out and
publicly calling for it to happen in
fact he and fellow Democrats were
suggesting that the IRS do just that and
then the IRS did that well Obama would
say well yeah but I didn't order anybody
to do that I'm the President of the
United States if I want to order
somebody to do that theoretically I
could but I didn't that was just people
taking the law into their own hands and
trying to forecast what I wanted well
Trump could easily say the same thing
here in September as all this was
getting started the Washington Post
reported that Trump told his acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney to hold off
on aid just before Trump called
Ukraine's new president and asked for
political investigations but weeks of
interviews with current and former
officials have yet to connect the dots
that Trump explicitly ordered the aid
withheld to force Ukraine to do
something for him right so that that is
obviously the big one if you can link it
directly to Trump if it was just people
around Trump who were getting out over
their skis because they were trying to
please Trump preemptively well that's
not gonna get Trump may then question
number two according to the Washington
Post what was Mick Mulvaney's role they
say if anyone knows why the aid was
paused it's likely Mulvaney he publicly
said from held up the money to try and
force Ukraine to investigate a
conspiracy theory about their
involvement in the 2016 election he said
did Trump also mentioned to me the past
corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely no question about that but
that's it and that's why we held up the
money he tried to walk that back later
by saying there was no quid pro quo but
at the very least he said he knows the
aid was held up and why well yeah that's
true but again that's not a legitimate
right if Trump said I want to hold up
the aid until you
ukrane investigate corruption
surrounding 2016 I failed to understand
how that is any different in any way
from Senator Bob Menendez and two other
Democratic senators in 2018 sending a
letter to Ukraine saying if you don't
help with the Muller investigation to
get to the bottom of Russian
interference in the 2016 election then
we are gonna hold up the aid there is in
fact an ongoing investigation into
Ukrainian and Russian interference in
the American election right that the
results of the the origins of the Trump
Russia investigation from the IG are
supposed to come out very very soon like
sometime this month then there is the
question of Rudy Giuliani and this is
the big one to me because Rudy is the
guy who Trump dispatched to Ukrainian
and Rudy has the biggest mouth and the
man has no discipline whatsoever so was
Rudy deployed to Ukraine to go dig up
dirt explicitly on the Biden's or was
this about a swaging Trump's feelings
about 2016 was he investigating
corruption in Ukraine that had to do
with 2016 or was he looking forward to
sinking Joe Biden in 2020 by digging up
dirt on Joe Biden and the only person
who's gonna be able to testify to that
is Rudy Giuliani and Giuliani so far has
said publicly that his whole thing is
that he wants to defend Trump against
allegations well defending Trump against
allegations is in fact tied up in
something that does have national
security implications meaning if the
allegations are that Trump was involved
in skewing the election of 2016 and so
Giuliani is out there trying to dig up
other information about people
interfering in the 2016 election there's
nothing illegitimate about that we just
did a two and a half year investigation
about foreign interference in American
elections if however it was about
Giuliani taking up dirt on Biden in
order to benefit Trump for 2020 and then
Trump militarizing that with Ukrainian
foreign aid then you got a problem on
your hands like everything gets more of
this more of the analysis of impeachment
gait the day has arrived
ooh we'll get to all of that in just one
second first you need to go over to
Daley wire calm and subscribe why well
you're really missing out if you're not
head on over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe for as little as 10 bucks a
month you get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts our
full show library select bonus content
and our exclusive daily wire app which
is a pretty awesome feature if you
haven't checked it out yet our app it is
a beautiful beautiful app the technology
sparkling if you choose the new All
Access plan you'll get all of that plus
the legendary leftist ears tumblr and
brand-new ask me anything a style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis which is a lot
of fun so stop depriving yourself come
join the fun over at daily wire.com
slash subscribe go check it out right
now
[Music]
more questions from the Washington Post
that have yet to be answered again we
don't know Giuliani's were all we don't
know Mulvaney's row we don't know
whether Trump directly ordered any of
this the Washington Post suggest if
Giuliani was acting of his own volition
his motives are unclear we know that two
of his business associates were recently
indicted on campaign finance charges had
ties to Ukraine and State Department
officials have testified they may have
felt threatened by anti-corruption
efforts US diplomats were leading
against some Ukrainian officials okay
well let's say in the most nefarious
circumstance let's say that there's an
accusation made that these Ukrainian
officials were trying to make time with
the Trump administration by using
Giuliani as a funnel for information and
they were funneling damaging information
about Biden about Ukraine about
corruption via Giuliani to Trump does
that implicate Trump or go to Trump's
motive not really it mostly raises
questions about Giuliani
a fourth question is did Ukraine know
why it's military aid in an oval office
meeting or being withheld well in order
for them to know that presumably they
would have had to coordinate directly
with Trump so even answering this
question doesn't answer the fundamental
question which was what was Trump's
motive what was Trump's intent all right
let's say that Gordon someone was
misinterpreting fronts and then he went
over to Ukraine and said we want Biden
well without showing that someone was
told by Trump to go get Biden maybe
that's someone who is acting on his own
now cuz he hates Biden but because he is
trying to forecast the feelings of the
President of the United States
The Washington Post suggests someone
testified he told the Ukrainians they
were likely to get their aid released
when they announced an investigation
into Democrats but again likely to get
their aid released means that he is
speculating the acting in US ambassador
in Ukraine bill Taylor was in close
contact with the Ukrainians he testified
they knew what was being asked of them
and they didn't want to do it he said I
think it was becoming clear to the
Ukrainians that to get this meeting they
wanted they have to commit to pursuing
these investigations whether Ukraine
knew it was being forced into something
would go a long way to confirming a quid
pro quo but Democrats are actually
backing off of this proposition because
they don't like the idea they're gonna
have to actually prove the elements of
bribery instead they think that the
president's attempted to simply hold
back the taxpayer aid for unspecified
reasons could theoretically be enough
Jim Himes
Democrat of Connecticut he said
extortion doesn't require a you give me
this and I'll give you that kind of quid
pro quo it simply requires using your
muscle to get something that you don't
have
right - okay but you haven't established
what exactly he doesn't have a right to
yet or that he was applying muscle in
order to get that thing right if I tell
you that I am NOT going to pay you until
you give me that hamburger that's called
a free market transaction if I tell you
I'm not gonna pay you until you off my
wife that is a very different sort of
transaction so we actually have to
determine what kind of transaction this
is and the fifth question is really the
big one which is why did Trump withhold
the aid in the first place like what was
the point what was Trump's issue with
Ukraine and again I think that the
answer here is kind of obvious right I
don't think that Trump has been hiding
the ball Trump thinks that Ukraine is
hiding the CrowdStrike server ratings
they're hiding Hilary sir I don't know
why Rio I read too much Infowars he put
together some weird conspiracy theory
and now he's been out there proclaiming
that somewhere buried in the forests of
Kiev is is some Hillary Clinton's server
they took it from her bathroom they they
flew it over to Kiev they took it out
into the forest and they buried it under
a Dasha or something it's like it's but
I don't I don't get it okay but that was
Trump's belief he also believes
correctly that the Ukrainians were
working with the Hillary Clinton
campaign in 2016 that part is actually
true right it was reported by Politico
also he believes that something corrupt
is going on with Purisima and Biden and
he believes that that impacted the 2016
election because obviously if the
Ukrainians were working hand in glove
with the Obama administration to get him
and covering up for the Biden's that's a
big problem right so so he believes all
of those things are any of those beliefs
wrong sure I think the CrowdStrike thing
is completely unsubstantiated unter
Biden Joe Biden thing so far does not
have proper evidence to actually
substantiate the allegation but is it
illegal or impeach able for the
president to want things that he wants
investigated investigated not
necessarily I mean not really not unless
what you're talking about is the
president really attempting to leverage
American foreign aid on behalf of his
electoral results purely purely not as a
side effect of foreign policy purely
because he wanted Biden out okay and
that part honestly like I don't actually
see that in Trump's activity I'm trying
to people don't believe me when I said
it's obviously then you shouldn't right
I mean because the fact is I am a
conservative yeah I'm a Republican but
the fact is I don't actually see
objectively that Trump has ever had the
level of intent necessary
to do anything I don't think that he's
ever had the level of intent to put him
to eat a hamburger I think that it's
half accident when he eats a him like
hey I I really I guess the idea here is
that Trump like a laser beam focused in
on Joe Biden then he was like I'm gonna
withhold military aid to get Joe Biden
cuz Joe Biden is just so dangerous and I
have been following this Purisima thing
like a hawk or alternatively he has
thoughts and he vomits the thoughts
whenever he is asked about a particular
topic which one sounds more like Trump -
you thought vomit Trump or like a laser
beam 40 Ches planning out every move in
the Bally's Admiral Thrawn from the from
the post Star Wars trilogy yeah I don't
think so I don't think so okay so now we
need to introduce you to a couple of the
players who are going to become pretty
important in this whole impeachment
inquiry the Democrats have an
impeachment lawyer the Republicans have
an impeachment lawyer so the Democrats
impeachment lawyer is a person named
Daniel Goldman he spent a decade as an
assistant US attorney in Manhattan he
left that job in 2016 to become a TV
legal analyst but now he is going to be
questioning witnesses called to testify
about Trump's efforts to persuade
Ukraine to investigate a political rival
and alleged efforts to persuade Ukraine
to investigate a political rival would
be more honest Washington Post The
Washington Post reports that Goldman is
slotted to question each witness for 45
minutes followed by a five-minute
question sessions for each lawmaker
Stephen castor the general counsel for
the House Oversight Committee will be
the Republicans point man
apparently Goldman has been doing high
profile cases for quite a long time and
he has focused in specifically on
organized crime in 2017 when then
assistant US attorney Brooke Cuccinelli
was preparing for the trial of Billy
Walters a professional gambler who made
millions on insider stock trades she
knew would make big headlines because
the case involved Phil Mickelson
Cuccinelli said she requested Goldman to
be on the trial team because he has a
bit of swagger as a trial lawyer and
it's a confidence that serves him well
in a courtroom he's incredibly effective
Walter is one of the most successful
sports gamblers in Las Vegas history
rolled the dice against Cucinelli and
Goldman and lost Goldman has has a long
sort of he has a long history of
high-profile cases according to Preet
Bharara the former US attorney for the
Southern District
York whose Goldman's boss for years you
can see my interview with prepar on our
Sunday special we did it about a month
ago before the impeachment inquiry open
Ferrara said he was one of the go to
trial guys there's no case that sooo
complex for him he's a great prosecutor
he's got powerful presence to the extent
the public will be watching him and
looking for credible questioners quite
credible questioner I think they'll be
very impressed with Dan Goldman but
Barra said that the impeachment hearing
will be challenging even for a skilled
trial lawyer because of the proceedings
unusual nature he said impeachment is
fully 100% a legal event and that it's a
constitutional enterprise right from the
start at the same time the nature of the
constitutional proceeding is a dynamic
that includes two political branches so
it's political in that sense but not
political in the pejorative sense that's
how the founders wanted this to happen
he says that he thinks that that Goldman
will handle the spotlight well he had
Goldman by the way had prosecuted a
number of the jeanna VC mobsters
including a hit man named theosis of
Freddy Jesus he also prosecuted a
sprawling auto insurance fraud case
involving Russian organized crime at
figures so his job is going to be to
connect the dots on behalf of the
Democrats right this is this is the this
is the idea here okay meanwhile on the
Republican side of the aisle as a man
named Steven caster was the GOP staff
attorney The Washington Post reports
that caster will help lead the effort as
general counsel for the House Oversight
and Reform Committee castor has spent
his career avoiding media spotlight he's
risen through the ranks over nearly 15
years and seven consecutive
chairmanships to become the oversight
panel's top GOP lawyer a half-dozen
former colleagues and bosses praised him
as a straight-shooting attorney whose
deliberate low-key style will make him
an asset to Republicans amid intense
public scrutiny of the impeachment
hearings from our Oversight Committee
Chairman jason Chaffetz of Utah who left
the house in 2017 said quote it's not
something he would have asked for it's
not in his DNA task for something like
this he's a fairly unassuming guy but he
speaks with authority he'll just ask a
few simple questions and demonstrate
that there's no there there
injera lysa said the caster's job is to
focus on making complex things simple
eisah said he wouldn't want to play
poker because he doesn't give up what
he's thinking particularly easily caster
was originally hired by the Oversight
Committee chairman Tom Davis in 2005
he'd spent four years as a commercial
litigator at the Philadelphia and
Washington offices of the law from a
blank Rome one of his first
investigations involved the Bush
administration's response to Hurricane
Katrina as part of that probe the GOP
led committee held nine hearings obtain
more
half a million pages of documents and
released a 569 page final report
critical of the Bush White House also he
helped handle the probes of Benghazi and
the Fast and Furious scandal so a lot of
even Democrats suggest that this guy is
an institutionalist who is a who's a
solid lawyer so those will be two of the
faces that you see cropping up
throughout this entire process meanwhile
president from continues to fulminate
the best thing that Trump can do here is
to sit still I mean again for this has
always been true is true during the
Muller report it is true now the best
thing that Trump can do is to sit still
just sit down stop saying things right
but feel free to say this is a partisan
political witch-hunt right if you if
your Trump's if your Trump's team you're
telling him yeah keep saying that
because that obviously there's truth to
it I just keep saying that over and over
and over but other than that like stop
just stop doing things apparently
however inside the White House there are
constant conversations about firing
people which is obviously going to be a
bad move apparently Trump immediately
wanted to fire Mick Mulvaney a--from of
anyone out there and said there was a
quid pro quo according to the Washington
Post senior advisors have cautioned
Trump that removing Mulvaney at such a
sensitive time could be perilous both
because of Mo vania played an integral
role in the decision to freeze the aide
and because of the disruption that would
be caused by replacing one of trumps
most senior aides
one Trump advisor says I don't think
you'll see him going anywhere until
after December but the president was
very unhappy with that press conference
that was a very bad day for the
president well the problem is you Alstom
all veiny and now what exactly is
Mulvaney's interest in not going and
testifying about what Trump ordered him
to do particularly if he's the one who
ends up coming into the crosshairs here
Trump's advisors are saying well you
ousted Bolton and now Bolton is flirting
with testifying so why would it be smart
to get rid of Mulaney plus it would look
to the public the Democrats would make
the case that the reason you fired
Mulvaney is not because he was fibbing
or because he was exaggerating but
because he was telling the truth
that he said something you didn't like
so you fired him and by the way they're
gonna use the exact same logic with
regard to this other rumor which is that
Trump was apparently considering firing
the intelligence community Inspector
General who reported the whistleblower
complaint to Congress according to the
New York Times mr. Trump's private
complaints about a man named Michael
Atkinson the Intel community
the Inspector General who deemed the
complaints against him to be credible
according to the New York Times Trump's
private complaints about mr. Atkinson
have come as he is publicly questioned
his integrity and accused him of working
with the Democrats to sabotage his
presidency it's unclear about how far
trump's discussions about removing
Atkinson have progressed to people
familiar with what took place that they
thought Trump was just venting and
insisted mr. Atkinson dismissal was
never under serious consideration that
is probably true and but again sit still
sit still stop this it is not a smart
thing to do now who are the witnesses
who are gonna matter okay well the
people who'd spoke directly to Trump so
Gordon Sunland the EU ambassador as I've
said he's gonna matter the the testimony
of Rudy Giuliani when he is forced by a
court to testify which is quite likely
he will his testimony will matter John
Bolton if he is told to testify that
will matter because he can go to state
of mind for president Trump right though
those are all the ones that are going to
matter at this time now meanwhile the
Democrats are trying to beat Trump to
the punch a little bit here because the
Justice Department Inspector General is
now inviting witnesses to review his
draft of his Russia report and Democrats
are deeply afraid that the origins of
the Trump Russia report are simply gonna
lend credibility to Trump's claims that
they've been trying to target him via
the intelligence community since before
he was president of the United States
according to the Washington Post the
Justice Department's inspector general
has begun scheduling witnesses to review
draft sections of his report on the
FBI's investigation of president Trump's
2016 campaign the clearest indication
yet that the long-awaited document will
soon be released publicly people
familiar with the matter said and
there'll be a bombshell dropped right in
the middle of the impeachment hearings
if it turns out that there was
malfeasance by the Obama administration
in coordination perhaps with Ukrainian
sources as political reported that is
going to throw a bombshell into the
middle of this because then it looks
like Trump is really upset about
something that actually happened
Ukrainian coordination with members of
the Hillary campaign and the Obama
administration that Trump is really
upset about the about the coordination
of Democrats to suggest that he did
things that he did not do according to
the Washington Post several witnesses
have been scheduled are in talks to
review sections of the report dealing
with their testimony in the next two
weeks
that could mean public releases imminent
though the witnesses will be allowed to
submit feedback which could
theoretically spark spark more
investigative work and slow down the
process
but again if this thing is released in
the near future Wow it will it will
definitely throw a wrench into the
entire impeachment hearing and if it has
anything in it right the Washington Post
reported earlier this month the DOJ was
trying to release the report quickly one
person involved said November 20th was
being our guide as a target date lest
you forget today is November 13th so one
week from today in the middle of the
hearings the DOJ report on Trump Russia
investigation origins could break which
would be just wild another person
indicated the report was more likely to
be released after Thanksgiving but we
are we are starting to get close in
other words as the Washington Post
suggests correctly conservatives hope
the report will give them ammunition to
argue the FBI was corrupt in its pursuit
of Trump and his alleged ties to Russia
and Republican lawmakers have been
pressing the DOJ to make the report
public next week Senator Charles
Grassley of Iowa tweeted quote I will be
very disappointed and left to wonder
what the game is is someone at the FBI
or DOJ tying the IDS hands so yeah and
this is the next two weeks are going to
be a mess
welcome to the holiday season gang how
exciting it meanwhile the 2020 Democrats
are still in turmoil their field is just
a mess they they still have not decided
whether in fact they want a revolution
at the top of the Democratic ticket or
whether they simply want it returned to
normalcy Joe Biden would be the return
to normalcy camp candidate then you have
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
campaigning for the revolutionary title
certain candidates are basically done so
Connell Harris is basically finished
right she's down at 1% in the polls in
New Hampshire she's toast she can't
raise any money she's trying to make a
comeback in South Carolina and having no
success and so and why why well in one
clip III would go with probably it's
because of her crazy laugh I know I know
that's not a great reason to get rid of
a candidate but when the crazy laugh
attaches to lack of credibility and
ridiculous policy proposals you're
pretty much toast here's Kamala Harris
laughing eerily over the last couple of
days
and no one is laughing with her no one
is laughing with her hears by the way
she suggests that you text fearless to
seven oh seven eight five but after
hearing that laugh are you fearless or
are you fearful that she will burst out
of your closeted to attack your children
that laughs man that is a joker laughing
full-on Joker laughs oh my god I can't
imagine why she's seen no success
meanwhile Joe Biden is still stumbling
around and getting angry at people who
ask him basic questions so somebody had
the temerity to ask him about his
support from the 1994 crime bill and Joe
Biden got very frustrated and started
asking them personal questions every
single solitary remember a major black
mayor and Mayor in the country said we
had to respond to the violent crime rise
look at the truth that is absolutely
true champions and the majority of the
black caucus overwhelmingly supported
the number of violent crime has risen
after the violent crime went down kiddo
where do you go to school maybe here
okay
by the way Joe Biden is saying things
that are correct but he is a bit prickly
there okay the Democratic field is weak
which is why Hillary Clinton may be
thinking about jumping back in really
like she issues making noises about it's
never too late for Hillary Clinton never
too late ah just what America needs
another Trump Hillary election cycle
after an impeachment hearing just
fantastic okay time for a quick thing I
like and then a quick thing that I hate
and we'll be out of here so things that
I like in the middle of a book by
Yannick Wasserman who is an economist
it's it's called the marginal
revolutionaries and it is an excellent
book it is all about the Austrian School
of Economics I tend to think of myself
as an as a devotee of the Austrian
School of Economics but it talks about
the different sort of views within the
Austrian school right Hayek did not
agree with von Mises who did not agree
with Schumpeter right these were all
different thinkers and and it's a
fascinating sort of discussion of where
the Austrian school came from what its
thought processes were why in some cases
Austrian economics has been exaggerated
in terms of libertarianism a lot of
these economists were in favor of for
example progressive income tax it's it's
it really does lend a lot of color to to
some of the basic thought that you would
read if you just read the Road to
Serfdom it gives you a broader
background on the economists really did
shape America in tremendous ways because
the battle between the Austrian School
of Economics and then it's sort of
branching successor the Chicago School
of Economics on the one side and the
Keynes Ian's on the others it's really
shaped how Americans think about
economics and now of course you have the
actual Marxists who are coming back into
play which is absurd
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so if you think that the democratic
cities are good evidence that Democrats
should govern I have some news for you
San Francisco's new DA says that public
urination will not be prosecuted so
that's exciting stuff
chase abuddin the urine and feces
plagued urine and feces plague city's
incoming District Attorney according to
the Daily Caller
pledged during the campaign not to
prosecute public urination and other the
quality of life crimes if he was elected
he declared victory on Saturday night
after results showed him winning a
plurality of votes in the DA race he
said we will not prosecute cases
involving quality of life crimes crime
such as public camping offering or
soliciting sex public urination blocking
a sidewalk etc should not and will not
be prosecuted he said many of these
crimes are still being prosecuted we
have a long way to go to decriminalize
poverty and homelessness you're not
criminalizing poverty you are
criminalizing people sleeping on the
streets spreading disease living in
their own filth pooping on the sidewalks
pissing on the sidewalks blocking
children from going where they need to
go camping in public parks like is this
the America you want because the
radicals of the the radicals of the
Democratic Party this is the America
they want and by the way things are not
going fantastically well in democratic
government cities where they have taken
up this sort of this sort of policy the
New York Post reported that a homeless
man dumped a bucket of hot diarrhea on
an LA woman near the Hollywood Walk of
Fame
Heidi Van Tassel said she was about to
drive home from a Thai restaurant near
the famed tourist area in April when her
alleged assailant Jerry blessings
dragged her out of the vehicle he pulled
her over into the middle of the street
where he dumped a bucket of feces over
her head she said it was diarrhea hot
liquid I was soaked and it was coming
off my eyelashes and into my eyes
presumably presumably
that's always been okay if the I had
just dumped it if he just sort of like
pushed the bucket at her and it has sort
of spilled then I guess that's not
prosecutable in the city of Los Angeles
she was tested for infectious diseases
and and thank God she came up clean but
she said that apparently the paramedics
said that it looked like the man had
been saving all of this up for about a
month you know I mean you never want to
spend you definitely want to save the
investment potential is is high for hot
feces so America's liberal govern cities
just doin fantastically fantastically
well okay we will be back here a little
bit later today for two additional hours
of content I am also speaking tonight at
Boston University it should be
fascinating I think it will be
interesting I think you'll want to tune
in you can check that out at yah org
slash live you can also check it out at
daily wire.com
and on our Facebook page and on our
Twitter and all the rest of those places
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
for all of the impeachment updates the
day has arrived and the process has
begun I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Serling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 it was the best of times it was the
worst of times it was the age of make
America great again it was the age of
America was never really that great
it was the election season of hope it
was the election season of despair the
Atlantic Monthly and many others think
America is heading for a civil war it's
actually dedicating an entire issue to
how that Civil War might be avoided we
will examine how to bring our country
back from the brink check it out on the
Michael nul show
[Music]
you